ده زميلته في الجامعه لتناول الطعام
العشاء لكنه تناولها هي شخصيا
وسائل الاعلام وصفته باكل لحوم البشر
الاسم اي سيجاره
واكل جثتها المكان فرنسا
من يناير عام
سجى والمولود
دعى زميلته الهولنديه
لمنزله لمساعدته في ترجمه الشعر وتناول
طعام العشاء سويا
لكنها لم تكن تعلم انها دعوه لعشائها
الاخير الذي لم تدق
رصاصه اخترقت رقبه زميلته هكذا خطط سجى
لجريمته وبالفعل نفذ ما خطط له
اغتصبها بعد ان قتلها قطع جثتها وداوم على
اكل اجزاء منها لثلاثه ايام متتاليه كما
التقط صوره مرعبه لجريمه المروعه لصحبه
جثه القتيله او بمعنى ادق بصحبه ما تبقى
منها
الفتاه الهولنديه عبر تركها في احد
المتنزهات في المدينه لكن الشرطه الفرنسيه
القت القبض عليه متلبسا بصحبه حقائبه لم
ينكر القاتل فعلته واعترف للشرطه دون تردد
اكل هذه الفتاه كانت تعبير عن حبي لها كنت
اريد ان اشعر بوجود شخص احبه داخلي
لمده عامين قبل ان تتم محاكمته لكن بعد ان
عرض على هيئه المحكمه كان القرار باداعه
مصحه نفسيه لانه مختل عقليا وغير مؤهل
للمحاكمه
السلطات الفرنسيه بترحيله الى موطنه
في مصحه نفسيه يابانيه لكن الاطباء هناك
نفوا عنه صفه الجنون والاختلال العقلي بعد
فحصه
لم يكن نفسيا الانحراف الجنسي كان السبب
والدافعه وراء ارتكابه لجريته
اسقطت التهم الموجهه لسقاوه في فرنسا ولم
تتحصل السلطات اليابانيه على وثائقي
لادانته فصدر قرار بخروجه من المصحه عام
1985 وظل حرا طليقا حتى وفاته بالتهاب
الرئوي في الرابع والعشرين من نوفمبر عام
2022 بعد اكثر من اربعين عاما على جريمه
حياته سقاوه كانت مليئه بالشهره والاضواء
وتحول الى نجم في وسائل الاعلام اليابانيه
تلفزيونيه ونشر كتبا حققت مبيعات ضخمه
منها كتاب اكل لحوم البشر وكتاب ارغب في
اوكل